janvier 2015 courbevoie dans les hauts
de seine un homme met un coup de pied
dans les pratiques de la grande
distribution
élu municipal arash derambarsh récupère
à la fermeture d'un supermarché
ce qui part normalement à la poubelle
pour leur distribuer immédiatement
salade
c'est comme si vous n'apportez quel
citoyen à les acheter en fait dans un
supermarché à 20h30 et consommer ne
soient même aliments périmés dans
quelques heures emballages abîmée autant
de produits encore consommables mais que
les supermarchés n'ont plus le droit de
vendre mais rien ne les oblige à les
donner aux associations
la salade un sujet qui révoltent cet élu
de 36 ans qui part alors en croisade
médiatique
ils démarchent des stars court les
plateaux télévisés et lancent une
pétition pour obtenir une loi qui
imposerait le don des invendus des
supermarchés pour dire stop au gâchis
alimentaire
rejoignez et signer la pétition c'est la
vision plus de 200000 personnes vont la
signer fort de ce soutien populaire
arash derambarsh contacter les
politiques et au sénat
c'est nathalie goulet sénatrice u10 us
et de l'orne qui s'empare du sujet j'ai
suivi sa campagne
magnetic joe bas commente quelqu'un
aurait pu l'éviter surtout sur twitter
où il est omniprésent et en fait j'ai vu
j'avais noté que frédéric lefebvre il
dépose un amendement dans la loi macron
et donc j'ai décidé de faire la même
chose à l'article 10 et jeunes est
déposé et fait adopter
vous avez des supermarchés qui tous les
soirs jette d'où la nourriture
comestibles et qui de surcroît verse
dans les poubelles de l'eau de javel
pour être sûr que personne puisse venir
le récupérer cesser ces procédés sont
absolument insupportables
heureusement la société civile ne nous a
pas attendu mes chers collègues
ça fait belle lurette que ça se fait ici
et là je pense préférable que cette
proposition de loi qui est en cours de
travail et qui viendra dans l'est dans
les prochains mois devant la haute
assemblée
me semble un cadre plus approprié pour
traiter de ce sujet tout en partageant
l'ensemble des préoccupations
qui ont été ici rappeler par l'un et
l'autre d'entre vous et pour cet
amendement qui et contre qui s'abstient
cet amendement est voté à l'unanimité je
vous remercie
votée au sénat mais non retenue dans le
texte final de l'assemblée nationale
l'amendement est à nouveau adopté dans
le texte sur la transition énergétique
avant l'été mais le conseil
constitutionnel le rejette pour des
raisons de procédure ségolène royal
s'empare alors de ce sujet populaire et
médiatique gaspillage suite avec le coup
de pression de ségolène royal à la
grande distribution la ministre a
convoqué tout à l'heure les principales
enseignes pour signer des engagements
notamment celui de ne pas détruire les
invendus les distributeurs ne peuvent
délibérément rendre leur a vendu
alimentaire encore consommable impropre
à la consommation
les enseignes s'engagent sur le papier
pas convaincu les parlementaires
décident de poursuivre leur travail et
déposent une proposition de loi au sénat
comme à l'assemblée
pas question pour eux de s'en tenir aux
bonnes paroles
sur le terrain dans l'orne nathalie
goulet est venu voir comment cela se
passe avec la banque alimentaire
une des dix huit associations agréées
pour collecter les invendus de la grande
distribution dans ce supermarché on n'a
pas attendu d'y être obligé pour donner
aux associations
cela se pratique depuis des années
expliquez moi un peu la répartition des
produits dont 40 tonnes dans l'année ces
normes
oui de cluj expliquer ça se divisant
qu'est ce que la banque alimentaire
récupère au quotidien des produits qui
sont un peu défraîchi mais qu'ils sont
à la base on les aurait enlevées du
rayon donc les enlever les jeunes
actuels ou alors les mettre à
disposition de la banque alimentaire
pour nous il n'y a aucune perte de temps
et si ça peut faire profiter des gens
c'est le principal s'il y avait une voie
qui passerait
je pense que ça pourrait permettre une
dette encore davantage
nous saluons avec elle ça fonctionne
déjà très très bien comme ça
et c'est la plupart couverts vie si ces
pays
moi je t'ai mieux donner
merci de votre accueil énorme c'est avec
plaisir
une fois le camion chargé c'est au local
de l'association que s'opère la deuxième
étape de la collecte avec des règles
bien définies
quand ça vient là on a une chambre de
tri donc tout ce qui est fragile
parent a étrillé la descente
et on vous proposait affecter
immédiatement validée au niveau date au
niveau tant que radio effectuée
directement commune mais ça reste au
frais jusqu'à la livraison c'est un
foyer qui confie d'emballage pataky de
production germain veut alors on n'a pas
droit de mines tout ce qui est fait est
mixé des coupes extérieur n'a pas donné
les légendes à chier chaîne du froid
respecter bénévoles formés aux règles
d'hygiène et de sécurité
la banque alimentaire assure aussi une
traçabilité des produits en cas d'
alerte sanitaire
alors forcément l'initiative d'arâches
derambarsh suscite des interrogations
il a donné sans se soucier vraiment les
problèmes de sécurité alimentaire à lui
il a dit c'est des produits c'est le
coeur qui a parlé bon c'était très bien
mais il faut aussi savoir que quand on
donne on à la responsable mais le diable
se loge j'aurais détails
oui bon mais ça y est ils faire
important parce qu'en fait on reçoit
tous les jours des alertes alimentaires
des grands distributeurs
donc il faut qu'on sache où ces partis
nous y prendre directement qui prend son
cabas équivalent donné alors il n'y a
pas de traçabilité
ça s'est passé les cépages aux absa
cette banque alimentaire collecte 58
tonnes par an auprès de la grande
distribution
l'équivalent de 30 mille repas la loi
obligerait toutes les surfaces de plus
de 400 mètres carrés a donné un
changement énorme pour les associations
si la question est est ce que cette loi
est une obligatoire pour que ça marche
la réponse est probablement non ça veut
dire que faut qu'on soit plus musclée au
niveau bénévoles plus musclée au niveau
au niveau camion il ya une logistique à
mettre en place qui n'est pas celle
qu'on connaît actuellement qu'il faudra
probablement augmenter qui fera en tout
cas retravailler quoi pour nous je dis
bien que pour nous donc alimentaire de
l'ordre ça marche bien donc en fait la
crainte que j'ai exprimés c'est que
c'est un métier très fragile et je
voudrais comme tous les équilibres et je
voudrais qu'il reste mais c'est à dire
que quand vous quand vous quand vous
insérez de la contrainte
voilà où les choses se passent bien ça
braque les gens compagnie dans un
équilibre difficile à trouver
même les associations sont divisés les
banques alimentaires comme les restos du
coeur sont plutôt défavorables à une loi
alors qu action contre la faim comme la
croix-rouge soutiennent cette initiative
inspirée par arash derambarsh lui ne
souhaite pas opposer les différentes
démarches
c'est complètement complémentaires ce
que je propose par rapport aux restos du
coeur à la banque alimentaire ou à
toutes ces associations agréées qui
peuvent stocker la nourriture
je rappelle que les restos du coeur et
la banque alimentaire font des collectes
toute l'année au même moment les
enseignes jette tout de même 40 à 50 kg
ce sont des kilos ce sont une quantité
incompressibles que toutes les enseignes
jette tous les soirs c'est pour ça que
j'ai voulu en faire une loi
des supermarchés qui jetterait tout
l'espoir des denrées encore consommables
faux répond la grande distribution qui
estiment faire beaucoup dans ce domaine
depuis des années on se préoccupe
localement de trouver un moyen pour que
ces produits qu'on ne peut plus
commercialisés ne soit pas tirer
bêtement je t'aimais trouve une deuxième
vie une réutilisation possible des bons
élèves il en existe en effet
propriétaire de trois supermarchés dans
le nord
thomas peau chers et parfois surnommé le
géant vert depuis des années il a mis en
oeuvre une politique de lutte contre le
gaspillage à tous les niveaux de ces
établissements à commencer par le rayon
fruits et légumes comme la tomate la
plus proche de la caisse cette petite
imperfection là elle va faire que cette
semaine et que penser ne restera pas
beaucoup et on va remplacer celles de
tomates par une nouvelle mais on risque
de la disqualifier n'a posé de côté donc
aujourd'hui mais elle va faire partie de
mon petit panier de quatre saisons que
qu'on va constituer là et on va pouvoir
retrouver ce genre de choses
voilà c'est le sait un poivron alors
c'est vrai si vous les présenter comme
ça tout le monde achète un poivron qui
est parfait alors sa ronde vraiment en
cuisine on a voilà aujourd'hui on leur
propose là il se retrouve avec un
bouquet de persil non non il ya plus de
fruits sur des gros volumes comme les
tomates qu'on a à côté de nous c'est un
très joli ça peut représenter jusqu'à
12% gaspillage chaque jour ces 150 à 200
kilos de fruits et légumes retirés du
rayon pour le ré agencer on signifie
qu'on va retrouver mes produits et on a
vu tout à l'heure et qui sont proposés à
petit prix au même titre qu'on va
proposer ici des bananes turbulent
aspect idéal on va les proposer à tout
petit prix vous voyez c'est 30 centimes
les carnavals
je mange
ici c'est récupération à tous les rayons
en boulangerie les invendus de la veille
servent à fabriquer du pudding maison
les légumes vont te dans les soupes et
les fruits sont transformés en boisson à
l'arrière du magasin pour leur donner
une deuxième vie
rien ne se perd tout se transforme on va
tous revalorisé comme on fait ici ou là
on redonne beaucoup de valeur aux
produits qui a vendu plusieurs zéros du
pilot en général sous cette forme
transformer aussi rendre dans les
cagettes qu on confectionne directement
réunion et qu'on revend 3-0 les cinq
kilos donc en remixant tout ça ont
réussi à retraiter à ne pas envoyer en
valorisation énergétique à peu près 80 %
de nos besoins de produits organiques
sur l'ensemble du magasin du rayon frais
à la viande en passant par des
emballages d'épicerie abîmée tout n'est
pas réutilisable
c'est cette marchandise qui sera destiné
aux dons qui n'arrive qu'en bout de
chaîne et représente tout de même de
grosses quantités
bonjour
ouais
tous les jours des associations pas se
prendre la collecte des amendes
on a un espace de tri et de sélection
s'initie entre les produits qu'ils
doivent être identifiés comme tels par
les collaborateurs mine à côté et
l'immense majorité des produits à peu
près 90 % de fortis c'est pour des
raisons cosmétiques dans les fruits et
légumes pour la vie quitte à l'heure où
pour le poste c'est une question de
fraîcheur théorie remet sa dispo à titre
gratuit d'une association qui viennent
nous rencontrer et les autres produits
mais je pensais notamment par exemple à
ses produits la face et du jambon qui
était en promotion pour le voilà une
offre promotionnelle que l'autre deux
cas plus de trente gratuite la date et
au 21 c'est plus dans norma charte
fraîcheur s'est mis à dispo dans cette
zone des associations une pratique
volontaire mais aussi encouragés par une
belle incitation fiscale un crédit
d'impôt qui fonctionne comme celui pour
les particuliers qui font des dons aux
associations caritatives sur le don à 90
heures on semble redécouvrir ce qu'ils
appellent la loi coluche me semble
nous on permet à une entreprise de faire
de dons en nature je me retrouve
aujourd'hui honoré de pouvoir donner
plus de 120 tonnes de marchandises par
an dans cette entreprise
c'est donc 66 % la valeur de métaux ça
va représenter jusqu'à deux cent mille
euros par an il ya aussi un plafond
était déjà prévu tel 0 5%
0 5% du chiffre d'affaires par un coup
de pouce censée inciter toutes les
enseignes à s'engager il reste pourtant
du travail à faire
tous nationale son honneur elles sont
déployées très largement aujourd'hui je
peux dire sans trembler qu'une bonne
moitié de mes collègues dans
l'enseignement je fais partie mais
claire ont déployé le même genre de
mécanismes et 95 % des patrons de
magasins sont conscients qu'il va
falloir mettre en place les actions
parce que la communication politique un
peu rattrapé le sujet mais elle a pas
inventé le sujet si les politiques se
sont emparés du sujet c'est bien que de
nombreux magasins ne se sont pas encore
converti à ces bonnes pratiques
21h banlieue lyonnaise les gaspilleurs
ont donné rendez vous ce soir ce
collectif va faire les poubelles des
supermarchés de la région
on n'est pas comprend pas nos vacances
en mai tout bête c'est pas le meilleur
endroit
by ap
ils s'introduisent en toute illégalité
dans les arrière-cours des magasins de
la grande distribution pour faire leur
marché à leur manière du coup laissé un
plan on vous met régulièrement et du
coup en fait ici c'est super bizarre
parce qu'ils trient tous les aliments et
du coup on à la benne de pain en à la
benne de viande
regarde c'est parti pour 15 minutes de
récupération avec leurs propres règles
sanitaires
ouais c'est la vienne le jour et tu vois
là par contre c'est gonflé donc c'est
pas bon mais c'est la couleur elle est
bonne saison 7 mais tu vois ça tu es
sous vide mais crevettes la pole et à
mon avis ça vaut le coup d'être tentée
merguez elles sont bien rouge
sa date du 21 donc là il va falloir
faire attention mais normalement c'est
bon et franchement tu as et même pas
nous fait donc dans le raisin le raisin
il a l'air bon à manger des papouilles
où pourtant il est là du coup je pense
on la sent un cabas en dessous
et il est nickel assez typiquement
le type d'aliments frais de fruits frais
ou on comprend pas du tout pourquoi ça a
été fait mais en fait quand on fait la
récup on se pose quelques questions
c'est pourquoi ça a été jetée est cité
en bon état et site est comestible
du coup par exemple les produits ou le
packaging il va être un peu bon fait ça
veut dire que c'est passé mais par
exemple ce genre de raisin on se demande
clairement pourquoi il a été jeté
c'est fini
cette nuit-là quatre enseignes de
marques différentes seront visités un
véritable butin est collectée pour une
redistribution le lendemain dans le
centre-ville de lui
13 heures place bellecourt un étal un
peu particulier s'installe habitués et
curieux attendre le lancement de la
distribution non sans écouter le message
des membres du collectif dont nous
préserverons l'anonyme des gaspilleurs
hier soir on a récupéré 300 kg de
nourriture dans trois supermarchés dans
la banlieue lyonnaise
aujourd'hui on se met rue de la ré
change à chaque fois de lieu pour
distribuer toute cette nourriture que
aussi la vente à ce que votre fils est
là pour la distribuer gratuitement à
tous et pourquoi à tous parce que les
pauvres en fait don parce qu'une journée
c'est économique merde donc enceinte
vous pouvez y aller à ancrer que la
dessert salé sucré ya seulement coup
l'effort doit être l'éthique est ici et
et vous pouvez vous approchez et si vous
avez faim c'est parti vous étiez c'est
quoi le message bas le message que c'est
aberrant que le gaspillage alimentaire
continue que malgré les bonnes pratiques
soi-disant des grandes surfaces
et quand même 300 kg dans les poubelles
en a fait quatre magasins on aimerait
bien avoir les chiffres du gaspillage
alimentaire pour pouvoir contrôler ça
l'a conduit à tout le monde comme quoi
c'est les consommateurs qui gaspille
plus mais à mon avis ce qu'on a là c'est
quand même beaucoup plus que chacun de
gaspiller en une année on peut se
mobiliser contre le gaspillage
alimentaire et faire bouger les choses
du bas avant d'attendre que les
politiques se bouger le fasse pour nos
enfants
toute cette nourriture jetée dont une
bonne partie avant la date de péremption
suscite l'indignation mais c'est une
honte
25 09
je pense que la moitié de la planète qui
a faim
elham enfants jack adam de voir tout ça
dans les parages absolument donner
l'opération est un succès le stand est
presque vide et le message est passé
la grande distribution en a pris pour
son grade
une loi permettrait-elle d'empêcher ce
grand gaspillage pour s'en rendre compte
direction la belgique et la banlieue de
liège bienvenue à herstal l'île de 40000
habitants est pionnière en termes de
lutte anti gaspillage dès 2013 le maire
a imposé le don des invendus des grandes
surfaces au samedi localement nous
pouvons également agir et c'est comme ça
qu'on essaie de trouver une formule pour
pousser la grande distribution à
redistribuer leurs avant qu on essaie
toujours pas toujours les faits il y à
de la résistance au changement aux
changements d'habitudes et notamment au
niveau de la grande distribution
dans cette enseigne on a été volontaire
pour lancer le projet et chaque matin
les mêmes gestes sont répétées donc on
regarde les dates qui ne sont plus
vendable ici ils vont vous voyez il a à
la date du 3 10 10
nous sommes le 30 mai par contre ce
n'est plus vendeur pour pour les clients
donc nous retirons de la vente nous de
ce canon comme ça nous avons une trace
de ce que nous donnons aux associations
et puis nous mettons ça dans un bac
comme nous avons terminé le rayon nous
allons mettre ça au frais pour respecter
la chaîne de froid et vers 9h09 caisse
l'association bière on sort les papiers
avec les articles qui sont imprimés su
comme ça ils ont une trace de ce que de
ce qu'ils prennent et nous aussi
ici la loi n'a pas changé grand chose
car ce magasin était déjà engagée et
voit désormais plus loin mais vous savez
on le fait depuis depuis des années des
dizaines d'années est donc pour nous il
ya rien qui a changé on pourrait même
aller plus loin on est carrefour en
belgique ne demanderait pas plus que
chaque magasin le fasse que chaque
association puisse en profiter et qu'on
passe par un logiciel au niveau national
où chaque association soit contrôlé par
la sq a bien évidemment par le
gouvernement et que les invendus que
nous mettons à disposition des
associations soient également cherché et
donc redistribuer ceux qui en ont besoin
nous demandons pas mieux en belgique pas
de crédit d'impôt généreux comme en
france et pourtant tout le monde s'y est
mis
ce que je
dire c'est qu'en belgique c'est nous ne
faisons pas pour deux raisons fiscales
ou financière en belgique nous le
faisons parce que ça fait partie de
notre politique en belgique et de deux
carrefours celle anti gaspi ce sont les
hommes et c'est la biodiversité et c'est
de savoir que quand on a des produits
des invendus s'il ya quelqu'un d'autre
qui peut en bénéficier
faut le donner à quelqu'un d'autre lieu
de jeter dans cette ville seul un
établissement reçu une amende de 5000
euros et s'est depuis converti aux dons
alimentaires et les autorités sanitaires
ont modifié leurs règles pour favoriser
ces initiatives la traçabilité a
notamment été fortement allégé les
barrières ont été revus pour les banques
alimentaires surtout au niveau de la
traçabilité pour que cette lourdeur
administrative qui est clairement
considéré comme une barrière pour les
entreprises
à juste titre pour des associations
caritatives on ne peut pas passer les
trois quarts de sa journée à remplir des
papiers et bien la sq à lagence en a
tenu compte et a permis par cet arrêté
ministériel et cet assouplissement
spécifique pour les banques alimentaires
a permis la de faire perdurer l'activité
de d'associations caritatives
d'autres villes belges ont depuis repris
cette idée et le maire d'herstal
espèrent désormais une initiative
européenne
on veut viser c'est un élément important
toutes les initiatives dans les
différents pays sont intéressantes et
j'ai eu l'occasion notamment en france
d'avoir un échange d'expériences sur le
thème est de participer aussi à une
pétition au niveau international pour
essayer de sensibiliser un maximum de
personnes en france
une commune ne peut pas imposer cette
mesure seule une loi le permettraient
plus d'un mois après l'accord signé par
les enseignes de grande distribution
avec ségolène royal
nous sommes retournés à courbevoie en
compagnie d'un rage derambarsh en caméra
cachée
pour voir si les pratiques avaient bougé
dans cette enseigne qui a trois magasins
sur la commune rien n'avait été mis en
place jusqu'au mois d'août
je vais revoir la redistribution mais
ici on fait toujours un créneau si vous
avez un jeune et je cherchais je double
effet qu'il avait une consigne du siège
s'est donc imposé dans une autre en
revanche une employée confirme les
mauvaises pratiques les savoirs baisse
sectorielle après
autorisant l'importation
la direction rappellera le lendemain
pour confirmer son refus de donner pour
une redistribution immédiate et aucune
convention n'est encore signé avec une
association l'engagement volontaire
n'étant pas suffisant
les parlementaires examineront un texte
dans les prochains mois qui obligera aux
dons et encadrera la collecte c'est un
vrai sujet je crois que le talent
d'arâches d'aruba jetant dans tout ce
dossier
ça a été de rendre extrêmement visible
encore une fois un problème qui touche à
l'éthique au religieux au sacré de la
nourriture extra donc ça nous touche
tous évidemment
donc je crois que c'est une c'est un
très bon sujet et donc on est aux
confins de la générosité et
une vraie plateforme de gestion avec des
bénévoles qui doivent être formés avec
une véritable logistique et ça on peut
décemment pas le laisser entre les mains
de petites associations qui pourraient
pas le faire
un texte qui s'attaquera en fin au
gaspillage de la grande distribution un
secteur essentiel mais responsable de
moins de 10% du phénomène rien
concernant les citoyens qui seraient
pourtant responsable d'environ 70% de ce
gâchis et qui ont un rôle majeur à jouer
dans ce domaine